[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Marissa,
it's such a pleasure to
have you here today.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> Welcome back to Stanford.
>> I'm very excited to be here.
>> I'd love to start out with
your time at Stanford here.
So, you came in pre-med with
ambitions to become a physician, and
you transitioned over to symbolic systems.
What was that pivot like?
>> Well so, I was very precise in
what I thought I wanted to do.
I had looked at a lot of schools before
picking Stanford and in those travels,
I had met this really fascinating woman,
very famous pediatric heart
surgeon who works at Duke.
And her name is Marjorie Tripp.
And I talked to her, and she said,
I I'm a doctor, I do extraordinary cases,
but I also teach at the med school and
I thought, that sounded so great.
So, I realized that wasn't interested
in hearts, but I was like, I'll
be a pediatric neurosurgeon, I love kids,
and I'm very interested in the brain,
how it develops, so
I came here very intent on that.
And through my freshman year, the
chemistry course started getting going on,
the biology core, went home for
the summer after my freshman year and
kind of compared notes with all of my
different friends, I'm from Wisconsin,
who'd gone to different schools.
And I realized that we were learning
very much the same things all over.
And I thought, I'd had the opportunity to
go to University of Wisconsin Madison,
it's a great school.
And, because of various scholarships and
things,
that would have been a nearly free option.
Stanford, on the other hand,
is very much not free.,
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's still that way.
And I thought to myself, wait,
I'm taking my parents retirement accounts.
We're investing a lot here, and
I should do something at Stanford
that's really unique to Stanford.
And something that can be done
just especially here, and so
I started thinking about the fact
that I would have a lot of
time later in life to specialize, and
go on, probably do other degrees.
And, so
I was thinking of what I wanted to do.
And as I was flying back that fall
to come back to my sophomore year,
I was going through the course catalog and
I found this department called
Symbolic Systems and it had Philosophy,
Psychology, Linguistics and
Computer Science all wrapped into one.
And I knew the staff was
very strong in psychology,
very strong in computer science.
I had taken CS 105A the previous year,
which is funny because it's the computer
science course for non-majors.
And the fact that the lecturer opens
the class the first day and says,
studies have shown that exactly
two of you will go on to
do anything additional in
computer science ever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In a sea of 400 people
[CROSSTALK] yeah.
And so, and I knew I liked computer
science though and I had done well in that
class, and interested in philosophy but
didn't know a lot about linguistics.
Came back, took the introductory syntax
course from Professor Tom Wassau.
And when I saw him because he was also the
director of the Symbolic Systems program,
and I knew he would try and
sell me on changing my major.
He was probably like, okay, look,
there's a special program,
most colleges don't have Symbolic Systems.
It combines some of the departments
whereas Stanford is really strong.
It was something that
was of interest to me.
And, the idea of Symbolic Systems is
really, how do people learn and think?
So, that interest I had in
neuroscience was carried over
because I realized I was less
interested in cutting up brains and
more interested in how do you learn,
how do you think?
because it's cognitive psychology.
How do people learn?
Logic, how do people reason?
Linguistics, how do people
express themselves?
And then computer science, can you
have a computer that does the same?
So AI was of a real interest.
But anyway, I want to talk about
Sir Wassau, when I walked in and I said,
I'm thinking about Symbolic Systems,
I'm taking your intro to syntax course.
And he said, [SOUND] you should absolutely
become a Symbolic Systems major.
And I knew he would say that, but
then he kind of did this interesting kind
of reverse psychology twist where he said,
you should absolutely be
a Symbolic Systems major.
And I thought he would say because the
classes are so good, the lecturers are so
good, the professors are so good.
But he said, you should absolutely
be a Symbolic Systems major.
All the most interesting
Stanford students are.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it was almost like if you weren't,
you weren't interesting.
But I have to say, it was one of the
things that I learned in that, and also
went on to learn it at Google and other
places at some of my internships, etc.
Is the Symbolic Systems major,
that time and I believe it's true today,
it's obviously true here at GSB,
was just filled with really,
really interesting students.
And I learned as much from the people
around me as I did from my professors,
the people in my study groups, the people
I went on to do an honor's thesis,
there were five of us in that major
that year that did an honor's thesis,
we met every week.
And people were doing musical puppets,
and could you do Stereovision
with cheap web cameras, and they were
just doing really interesting things.
And so, it was a terrific decision.
I will say it was a little bit scary,
because at the same time,
people are like what is Symbolic Systems.
And still to this day,
I have to tell everyone what a Symbolic
Systems is, why does it make sense?
My father really wanted to know,
paying the bills for Stanford,
like, what is Symbolic Systems,
and what will you use it for?
But, it was an amazing major that really
let me experience the range of Stanford,
continue to go after my passions,
which really sort of center a lot
more around artificial intelligence.
>> Right.
>> And it also set up really amazing
set of opportunities posting effort.
>> That's great, so one of those
opportunities included joining
a 20 person startup,
which turned out to be the right choice.
But at the time,
what was that decision like,
turning down offers to teach at Carnegie
Mellon or to go work for McKenzie?
>> Yeah, well so
at the time Google was just eight people.
It was the spring of 1999.
It's funny, because I actually spent
the 97, 98 school year living in Schwab.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I wasn't a business school student,
but they had about 20 other students
who lived in the dorms for balance, so
I was one of the balance people in Schwab.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And it was the first year it was open
and I would go down every night and
work out on the treadmill, and
there were all these GSB students who were
very curious about who is this person
who's not in the GSB who's on
the treadmill every night?
And they would come, and then when they
would find out I was computer science,
they'd be like I've got a friend with
a startup or I've got a startup.
I mean, so I would literally go
down to the Schwab treadmill and
get job offers on the way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, that was kind of the process and
it was just that time.
The Internet was very heady and so
it was very easy to pick up offers.
In the end I picked up about 14 offers and
I had to sort of sort and
shift through them all,
shift and sort through them all.
And, there were a lot of different
things that weighed on me at the time.
And, it was easy for me to pick
the best offer of each type, right?
I knew if I was going to do consulting,
I was most interested in Mackenzie.
If I was going to do a big company,
I was most interested in Oracle.
I've done a lot of lecturing here at
Stanford and I had an offer to go to
Carnegie Mellon and
lecture in their Computer Science program.
And so, if I did that I would go there.
If I did a startup,
it was probably going to be Google.
But I found it very difficult to integrate
across the different disciplines because
the job offers were so different.
So, I went and I thought a lot about it,
I procrastinated a lot and I told myself
I had to make a decision on May 1st.
And, I have a friend who now
works at Yahoo with me but
was a friend of mine from undergrad and
did a joint JD MBA here at Stanford.
A good friend of mine named Andre Veneer.
One of my longest friends.
And Andre is amazing right?
He was like the econ poly sci like 4.3
grade point average, can analyze anything.
Crazy, was working at
McKinsey at the time and
I said okay, I just need somebody who
can help me really synthesize across all
these different types of jobs and
analyze it.
And so we sat down and
we had this big matrix where we had.
Location, salary, job trajectory,
happiness factor and
like I then remember there are even
things where we were like look,
we can't get these with the street values,
we need curves so we were like [LAUGH]
Plotting curves and these things like and
then we were like some of these even need
third dimension and
we were going crazy plotting all of this.
And we got really into the analysis of
the problem, and at about midnight,
I just got really overwhelmed and sort
of sat back and just got very emotional.
And I just didn't really notice because
he was deeply involved in graphing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And also it turned to me, and
he was like, what are you so upset about?
And I was like I just don't know.
I told myself I'd make
a job sitting around.
I just don't know.
There's still 14 choices on the table,
I just can't figure it out.
And got really upset and overwhelmed.
And Andre, I think not really
kind of quite where my head was at.
I said, Marissa,
this has been really fun for me.
[LAUGH] My daughter's like, really?
because it's not really fun for me.
And I found it very stressful and
he was like look, it's been fun for me.
You know I love graphing and
analyzing things.
And he's like I think I now understand
this problem as well as you do.
And he like, I have to tell you,
I think you're approaching it all wrong.
He's like, because I'm watching you, and
you are sitting here looking at these and
you're looking for the right choice.
That's interesting that you said
in your question the right choice.
And he's like you're sitting here and
you're looking for the right choice and
he's like, you think there's one
right choice and 13 wrong choices,
I guess I understand as well as you do and
that's just not what I see here at all.
He's like I see 14 very good choices and
then there's the one
that you're going to pick and commit to
and may create and feel good about and
he's like and it's not going to be
a matter of right versus wrong.
It's just like it's all good.
And then there's the one that's great and
you commit to.
And people have asked me what's the best
piece of advice I've ever gotten?
And it's easily,
it was that moment from Andre.
And that, because he's like,
look, a lot of times, smart people when
they get really committed to a problem,
start to analyze it as if there's only one
great option and all the others are not.
And that's just not how life works and
it's important to realize when you get
really overwhelmed in those kinds
of choices to think about it.
To really think about it that way.
And so look, go to bed, sleep on it, and
whatever you think of first thing in
the morning that's what you should do.
And he's like, there's going to be a ton
of reasons you can articulate why you're
picking that,
there's going to be some reasons that
you can't articulate why you're
picking that and follow your gut.
Because you really have analyzed and
understood it.
So I went to bed, woke up in the morning
and I wanted to work at Google.
I wanted to work at Google because I felt
like the smartest people were there back
to Tom Mosso's comment about always work
and surround yourself with interesting and
smart people.
I wanted to work at Google because
I felt really unprepared to do it,
like the name itself
could be a punch line.
I could imagine future family reunions
like when Marissa graduated from Stanford
she went to this company called,
get this, Google.
>> [LAUGH]
>> She majored in symbolic and
then she went to Google, and.
It was very high risk, but I thought,
well, look, if there's ever a time when
I'm going to take that kind of risk,
it was then, it was not now.
Professor Roberts was a long-time mentor
of mine in the computer science world.
And he said look,
this is a great moment to go to and
participate in an entrepreneurial culture,
in the startup culture.
He's like no one's going to fault you, you
graduated with a computer science degree
in 1999, for going to a start up and
taking a risk.
He's like you can always pursue
some of these other options later.
But that was I just think
very much the right choice.
For me it was about the smartest
people being there and
doing something I didn't feel ready to do.
When I thought about how to
make the choice, those were,
I had all the different things in the
matrix, but ultimately, I thought about
some of the best choices I had made, and
almost all the best choices I had made.
Choosing to come to Stanford,
changing my major,
different internships I gone to: they were
all very different types of decisions, but
the two things where I always looked for
the smartest people I could find, and
I always did something I felt
a little unprepared to do.
>> Absolutely.
So now its come full circle because
you're former mentor at Google,
Eric Schmitz teaches of
course here at GSB and
I have the privilege of speaking
to him this morning about you and
he had to say about the associate particle
energy program that you started at Google,
that it was quote influential in
changing the industry forever.
It produce all of our best leaders and
many leaders at startups around us.
So given that, what is it that you are
most proud of from your time at Google?
>> I mean I'm very proud of the associate
product management program.
I did run it for ten years.
We hired on average about 20 people
a year, sometimes larger classes, so
about 250, I call them my kids
because they are my kids.
Like I go to their weddings, I buy baby
presents and presents for their kids.
It's been amazing to watch
them all grow up, and
they have populated the leadership
positions, and basically Airbnb, Dropbox,
Uber, Facebook, Twitter,
have all taken leaders on that program,
including a lot of the leaders today
at Google coming through that.
So I'm very proud of that, but
I think it's hard to beat the feeling
that we created a technology and
a product and
a business that changed the world.
When you look at Google, and
it was such a privilege and
an honor to be part of a team and
play a role in that.
I still remember I started
at Google in June, and
that December, the start up lifestyle,
you don't get a lot of time off.
And I managed that December to get away,
and go to Switzerland,
and I walked into a cyber-cafe.
They still had those then.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
there was somebody using
Google on the screen.
The same way I'd remember sometimes
when I was backpacking around
Europe after I graduated
from undergraduate,
I saw a Stanford sweatshirt on
the streets of, I think it was Florence.
And you see so many of them in your
everyday life here at Stanford that you
didn't even think about it.
I was like wait,
that's a Stanford sweatshirt,
what's it doing here in Florence?
It must be a Stanford student.
Same thing, like I had gotten so
used to seeing the Google homepage and
the Google results page,
I didn't even think about it.
I remember walking in to that cyber cafe,
seeing it, and
then all of a sudden being like
wait like I'm in Switzerland.
They're using Google in Switzerland.
There's this little project that
there's like 20 of us working
on on the other side of the world and
it's made it's way all the way here and
there's somebody using it.
And it really showed me in that moment how
fast the Internet allows technology to
move and how quickly you can deploy
something and really get it to scale and
to a global impact which is when you think
about what the internet has done, and
what type of impact it's enabled,
it's really amazing.
But that feeling I had, that December,
seeing that search screen
on that cyber cafe in Switzerland,
I still have today.
I still am very proud of the impact
that Google has had overall, and
I think at both Google and Yahoo,
I had to write a post this past
summer when we sold Yahoo to Verizon about
the company and there's so many things
that make Yahoo amazing, there's so
many things that make Google amazing.
But for me,
it's just a real privilege to work at
a company that's changed the world.
And you can make that argument for
both Google and
Yahoo very easily and
that's really what I'm most proud of.
>> Okay.
You've mentioned earlier that part of
the reason that you knew that Google
is the right decision that you made.
That you decided to make right,
is that you didn't feel prepared.
So, stepping into Yahoo as
the fourth CEO in 12 months,
turning the company around from a medium
business into a products company,
did you feel prepared for that role?
>> No.
And I think that's probably one of
the things that attracted
me Attracted me to it.
But I think the other element of it,
is while I've always respected,
I've known about Yahoo, I knew about
Yahoo back with it was still Dave's and
Jerry's guide to the worldwide web.
And Jerry Yang used to keep notes
about what the new cool site for
the week was going to
be in his CS directory.
So we were always trying
to hack his account and
hope that he had left the permissions
as world readable and
we would all get a little insight into the
new websites that were going to get added
to the new Yahoo directory that week.
And so
I'd known about Yahoo very early on.
And obviously, at Google, we really,
really looked up to Yahoo,
ran a Yahoo account in the summer of 2000.
It was a huge step forward for the
company, it's something we had worked at,
on, and towards the entire
time I had worked there.
So we'd worked on it for more than
a year when it finally came together.
And people love Yahoo and I think
that when I look at the service and
the role this played in the industry,
I think a lot about the products and
the services and things we all create
as art because they really are.
And a couple of years ago,
I met a friend in the city who has
a little gallery as like a side business.
I said, well, how do you decide
what artists to put in the gallery?
And he said, well I like local artists,
because I like to support local people.
And he's like, but
I also like art from people who are nice.
And he's like, because life is too short
to work with people who aren't nice.
And he's like also with an artist you
can feel if they're not nice in the art.
And I thought that was really interesting.
because you feel like when your in art
museum and you look at piece of artwork,
you can feel when the people
who are kind of tormented or
they're angry,
you can feel it in their artwork.
And I thought was actually
really insightful, and
if you think about it, and
women in particular relate to this.
You can tell when the designer of
your clothing likes women, or not.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay.
Depending on shoes,
other things, you can feel that.
Yahoo, and all those years, one I
really respected, what they created and
what they built.
But you could also tell that the people
at Yahoo were nice, and were fun and
they're hearts were in the right place.
Even though there were a lot times
when the leadership and the board and
all those different parts of
the company had their challenges.
You could tell that when you use
the service, the people there really
took a lot of inspiration and
joy out of the work that they did.
And my hope was going to Yahoo,
that that layer of the company was
still there and it very much was.
>> That's great.
So building on that point of
the talent within the company,
you were highly inquisitive in
the earlier years of your time at Yahoo.
Some acquisitions were for
technology, others were acqui-hires.
Do you think that that was enough to
transform the company's core mission from
being media oriented, into a products
company at the leading edge of mobile?
>> Well, I'm proud of
the different things that we did.
And I think that there's a lot
of different elements to
what is unfolded at Yahoo
in the past few years.
But the one thing is we had about
a $5 billion base of revenue
that was declining about 10% per year.
And when I had got there at Yahoo, one of
the thing was I like to work hard, and
I'm a workaholic, and
I like to work on really hard problems.
When I got there, we sort of looked at
the 10 to 12 different lines of business.
And every single one of
them was in decline.
And when I asked the current leaders for
the company how are we going to get any
of those growing, nobody had any ideas.
The answer was they're going to decline,
they're going to decline, for
the foreseeable future.
They're going to decline based on
industry trends like, they're declining.
That's a pretty harrowing diagnosis
when you're the new CEO coming
into a turnaround.
It's like, wait,
I've got to get revenue growing, and
we've got ten business lines
that are all decaying,
and we're losing about half a million
dollars a year of top line.
And no one has any idea
how to turn it around.
And so, when you're a turnaround CEO,
you've got to make a decision.
Can you turn around the existing lines
of business and get them growing again?
Or do you have to invent
new lines of business?
And so, it became very clear,
within a matter of weeks of arriving,
we need to create new lines of business.
And so for us, that really became
about mobile, not only just products,
but mobile.
And the issue is that Yahoo, when I
arrived, had depending on how you counted
it between 30 and 60 mobile
engineers in a company of 14,000.
So basically at about $11 million
in mobile revenue in 2011 makes it
easy to remember.
So you're like wait, $11 million
of revenue inside of $5 billion.
30 people inside of 14,000.
And I just told the whole board we're
going to turn the company around by
betting on mobile.
And so we said okay,
we really need to make this move fast.
And the good news is,
mobile was taking over the world, and
there was a real technology, companies
can reinvent themselves in waves.
When you look at IBM rode the wave to
services, Amazon rode the wave to Cloud,
they didn't even really need
to turn themselves around.
But these kinds of waves
can really lift companies.
I said look, I think the wave that
we need to catch is mobile, and
we're late catching that wave.
But we need to catch it.
So we went about doing different
types of acquisitions.
I always thought about acquisitions
in three different buckets.
Small, medium, large, and
the small, medium, and
large each had a different purpose.
We bought a lot of small companies for
the talent, getting teams in the door and
getting them in the door quickly enough
because we needed to move fast and
just start shipping mobile products.
Getting the mobile apps out there,
start growing our user base,
which at the time was tens of millions of
users, on mobile today is 650 million.
Grow that mobile revenue from $11 million
to, last year it was $1.5 billion.
So if we grew $1.5 billion
of revenue in four years.
And now it looks easy, and
looks like it was the right bet.
And the strategy looks like it worked.
But at the time,
there was a lot of debate.
Should we do HTML5 or
should we do mobile apps?
Does Blackberry matter versus iOS and
Android.
To credit to the team,
we made a lot of those decisions,
those strategic decisions right
in the moment when we got there.
Issues in revenue remained flat,
because we also had this decline that
we were trying to fill in the gap.
So even all that growth
just basically offset
the revenue that was otherwise
leaving the company.
But we did small acquisitions for teams.
We did medium acquisitions for
technology and teams basically.
For example, like a good,
I call them building blocks.
We bought a company called Zombie that was
really good at organizing contacts and
analyzing your email.
And we bought that to become a new
foundational block for Yahoo Mail,
which is our biggest product.
And then we also took some big
strategic bets, like Tumblr and
BrightRoll, because I really feel that
if you look at technology companies,
they reinvent themselves
through acquisitions.
Sometimes a new product idea comes
from within, like Amazon Web Services.
A lot of times if you look at Google,
how transformational Android and
YouTube were for them.
Facebook, how transformational
Instagram and Whatsapp are.
You've gotta make some big bets and
those can really help reinvent.
And so, I felt that we needed to
do everything that we could given
some of the size of the task to both work
to invent new business lines inside.
But also try and
inject new talent and new strategic ideas
that could help without reinvention.
>> Despite the fact that that strategy
seems to have played out fairly well.
You remain as CEO, as a company,
you remain under a lot of public scrutiny.
That's perhaps never been the case more so
than today,
given that privacy concerns and security.
So given that, as a leader,
how do you rise above the criticism and
And as a person,
how do you not take that heart?
>> A couple of things,
I just don't read it, and
that might sound-
>> [LAUGH]
>> That might sound tone deaf.
But I feel like if you read it,
it changes who you are and
how you think about things.
If something's, if one of your decisions
gets reinforced as being super,
super smart, but it's actually wrong, and
you read that this was
the smartest decision ever,
reading that's going to make you less
likely to abandon it or change course.
If you made the best decision ever and
you read that no, it's probably wrong,
it's going to make you
more likely to abandon it.
And the truth is, the press is the press.
There are some times when they're smart,
and
there are some times when they're right.
But they don't have half
of the information,
even close to half of the information
that you have being in the company,
in terms of what's likely to play out and
what's not.
And so to make decisions or allow
your decision-making to be influenced
by a third party who has a fraction
of the information that you
have, just overall isn't
a great strategy to me.
That said,
I try not to be deaf to it, right.
I've got a PR team that will summarize
some of the bigger issues and
points that are being made.
I also have a husband.
If I'm worried enough about something,
I'll ask him like, hey [LAUGH].
I am on Twitter, I read headlines.
I tend not to click on them, but I'll be
like, I'm seeing this headline a lot.
What's going on with that?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I do read other things.
I just don't tend to read
things about Yahoo or myself.
I try and have those, because I also think
that if you're going to get criticism,
it always sounds better coming
from someone who loves you.
>> I would agree.
>> Or someone that you work with and
have a relationship with.
I remember there was,
less of a scholar and pundit.
But I remember I saw an interview
with Bradley Cooper, the actor,
on the Late Night talk show once.
And he said,
do you know what I've discovered?
I discovered if you ever
wanted to feel really,
really bad about yourself,
go read about yourself on the Internet.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So it works if you're an actor, or
it works if you're a business leader.
Or, by the way,
it works if you're a high school student.
All right, it is a problem.
But the point is,
you just can't let that shape who you are.
And so
you either have to have guidelines for
how you're going to absorb it, like I do.
Or you have to have very thick skin.
I tend to think I have
a little bit of both.
But you have to have a way of
cutting through all that noise,
to what's a valid criticism that
needs to be acted on and what isn't?
>> We have a motto here at the GSB.
It's somewhat tongue-in-cheek,
that feedback is a gift, and
all feedback is a gift.
>> Well, I think, yeah, on the flip side,
one of my favorite colleagues at
Google is a guy named Alan Eustace.
And he rolled this thing
in a one-on-one once.
Where he just said, Marissa,
the one reason that criticism
hurts is because it's almost
always some percent true.
Right, the question is,
is it 1% true or is it 75% true?
Or is it 100% true, right?
But he's like, that's why criticism
strikes a nerve with people.
Because there's almost
always some truth to it.
>> Absolutely.
In light of that, how did you think about
absorbing the feedback from Yahoo
employees and from those outside of
the company about both your own personal
decision to return to work shortly after
the birth of your three children,
as well as your policies regarding
employees working remotely, and the family
leave policies that you put in place.
>> Yeah,
I think that that's probably, I mean,
there's been a lot of things that have
been misunderstood about my time at Yahoo.
I think that my thoughts
on all of those things and
how they actually played out
are probably the most misunderstood.
A couple of things,
I have nothing against maternity leave.
Everyone should take them, if you can.
But I will say the company was just not in
the state where I could take a maternity
leave in either time that it came time for
me to have my children.
When I was at Google, Google has
glorious maternity leave policies.
I had been there for 12 years.
I could be, between a combination
of time that I had stored
up as well as maternity leave,
my plan was to take a six-month leave.
All right, and Google wasn't even
going to turn off my stock vesting.
I was going to have one of the best
compensated maternity leaves of all time
at Google.
And then this opportunity
at Yahoo presented itself.
I remember thinking wow,
if I take this, two months after I
get there I'm going to have a baby.
I can't be out for six months.
I can't go and be CEO for two months and
then be gone for three, four, six months.
And that just also wasn't fair to Yahoo,
given the state that it was in, and
how much time was really of the essence
to catch up in the mobile race, etc.
And so I thought to myself,
I just am going to to have to
do this in a different way.
I'm going to have to push to
come back to work sooner.
It doesn't mean that I don't think it's
reasonable to have maternity leave or
would advocate for people giving up
their maternity the way that I did.
But this was an opportunity.
I had an obligation to my employees,
to my shareholders.
And I also felt that time
was incredibly important.
At the same time, I also said to myself
okay, I've gotta come up with a way to
make sure that I can also be the best
mother that I can be, right.
And so what we basically came
up with is I was out for
eight to ten business days, and
I then was back in the office.
But, and a lot has been made of it.
It has been called a nursery, it's
actually a small closet off my office.
But I would bring my son
in to the office with me.
So we joked that the first day he came to
the office he had this little Ralph Lauren
navy and white little suit thing.
It was more comfy, it was kind of knit.
But it was like he had his office wear,
he was like the business baby [LAUGH].
And so he came in and
he was there in the office with me.
And I was there doing the job,
being in meetings.
And every four or five hours I would
go in, see him, do a conference call.
It turns out kids,
when they're learning to talk,
they just need to hear a lot of language.
And so I would just be on speaker phone.
So my son understands revenue and EBITDA,
and everything really well [LAUGH].
And so that's sort of how we worked it.
And it wasn't ideal, but
I had a lot of time with him.
I think I had a lot more time with
him than most people recognize.
And I almost ended up doing
my maternity leave inverted.
Right, some people are home for their
maternity leave, and calling into work.
I happened to be at work with my son
there, but it ultimately worked.
It gave me the time that
I needed to be CEO,
and also the time that I needed with him.
And then when we went to revise
our family leave policies,
because Yahoo previously didn't have
very generous family leave policies.
We said, look, I really believe in
taking it from the child's viewpoint.
And I said, look, because there's so
many different ways to have children now.
There's biological mothers,
there's adoption,
there's the atraditional families.
I said, okay, flip it around
from the child's perspective.
Any child of a Yahoo should have,
let's call it at least two months
at home with their Yahoo parent.
Be it mom, be it dad, etc.
And then biological moms of course,
also gets state afforded leave.
And so what we do now is any parent,
any new parent gets eight weeks in
the first year of the child's life.
And biological mothers can
get up to 16 weeks, so
basically four months of time off.
But that was something that
was overall important to me.
Because that time, whether you're in my
case where I was spending it in the office
or you're spending it at home with
your child, is incredibly important.
And for the work from home,
I may be eventually,
I'm just always the poster child for
being anti-work from home.
I actually have nothing
against work from home.
My brother works from home,
lots of people work from home.
And I think it's a perfectly
valid way to do things,
but One of the things that I experienced
when I first got to Yahoo is,
the company had been through so
much turbulence, and energy was low.
And one of the challenges I had was,
I had to re-energize the campus.
And it was just really hard, because
it was us and people who had dedicated
setups, where they were working
from home 100% of the time,
but it was the person who said, you know
what it's raining really hard today,
I think I'm going to work
from home on Wednesday.
And then we'd have high performing Yahoos,
coming and talking to me and saying,
hey you're here, we're building all this
stuff, we're doing all this stuff, and
it's really frustrating that every now and
then, I got this person on my team who
just doesn't show up for work, and
tells they're working from home but
it doesn't really feel like
they're working from home.
Right.
because I know, I mean to me,
when you got a dedicated setup,
you're probably really productive.
But I know, if I didn't have
a dedicated setup at home,
I'm just sitting there at the kitchen
counter, or on the couch doing email.
I'm productive, but I'm not as productive
as I am when I'm in the office, and
meeting with people and
interacting with people.
And so we said look,
work from home is fine.
This is not statement from, as it was
ultimately misconstrued in the media,
this is not a statement about whether or
not work from home is good or bad.
But this is Yahoo's moment.
We're an iconic company.
We're trying to return it to greatness.
We need all hands on deck.
And so the statement that we
ultimately released said look,
this is not even a permanent policy for
the company.
It's just that, for right now, for us
the right thing is, to have everybody who
isn't formally working from home,
because we do have about 100 people in
the company who do formally work from
home, you should be here in the office,
because this is our moment,
this is our time, and we need to seize it.
And so, that's really what that was about.
And ironically, it was unfortunately
characterized, as kind of coming raining
down on working moms, or
conflated with my maternity leave.
In truth, about 85% of the people
affected by that change were men.
And in total, there was about a hundred
people a day who work from home,
and there were about a hundred people or
so, where their status changed, and
that only 15 of them were women.
And you never know that from the thousands
of articles that were written.
>> Right.
We were talking behind
stage about your husband,
who is a venture-capitalist in the area.
You're from Wisconsin.
In thinking about raising
a family in Silicon Valley, and
in the spot light,
what concerns might you have for,
making sure that your children have
the same sort of childhood that you had?
>> Yeah.
So, I have three children.
I've got a four year old boy, and
identical twin girls who are one.
And no, they're amazing.
I would say, I wasn't sure,
I know this sounds funny, but
I wasn't sure about motherhood.
My husband was very gung ho,
we're having kids.
And I was like, okay.
[LAUGH].
And I have to say,
it is really just amazing overall.
I knew I loved kids, but
to me as I said, I had my APMs,
I love other people's kids,
do I need to have some of my own?
I mean it's really amazing.
I would encourage it for
absolutely everyone.
because it just gives you so
much perspective.
And you just realize that some of the
biggest impacts you can have in the world,
is raising those kids to be,
productive, creative, amazing people.
But to me, really I think it's
the timing and place is different.
That said, the values you provide
your children are the same,
that perspective,
to me ultimately remains the same.
And there's certainly challenges but, I
think that for Macallister who's a little
bit older, I want him to have
an overstimulated childhood.
I want him to be exposed to everything.
Art, science, I mean Palo Alto and
the Bay Area is just so amazing.
You've got retired Stanford
professors teaching science classes,
at the science museum in downtown
Palo Alto, which is unheard of.
There's bilingual Mandarin story time
around the block from our house.
Right, I mean it's really,
really an amazing gift to be
able to raise kids here, and
be able to expose them to so much.
And so,
helping them get expose to that, but
also having them realize that
the whole world isn't like that.
And my husband's from Denver,
I'm from Wisconsin, and
you go home and see the way
different parts of the country work.
And feeling that is important, and even
more so different places in the world.
So we tend to travel a lot, and
we want to make sure that we expose
our kids to a lot of different things.
But, interestingly I had a Stanford
professor, Terry Winograd,
who raised two absolutely
terrific daughters.
And I really admired
the way he raised his kids.
And, I'm friends with his wife, and
I asked her one time,
I said your girls are so terrific.
What did you do?
And she said one,
travel is really important.
Them understanding,
Silicon Valley's context in the world,
and how lots of different people live and
work is really important.
But she also said the other thing is,
a lot of people worry about all
the success of Silicon Valley and
all that, and the impact it will have,
and I think that weighs on everybody.
But, she also said the thing
you have to watch out for,
because of the proximity to Stanford,
is that you really need to make
sure that they understand that,
it's an issue of academic and
intellectual self-esteem.
But everybody here is so smart.
And when they're going to
the Palo Alto public schools, right?
They're going with the children
of brilliant engineers, and
brilliant professors,
and Stanford students.
And that, ultimately, yeah, there are some
things, they don't necessarily understand
how smart, how talented they are, because
of the context in which they grew up.
So making sure that your kids are really
confident, that they got good self-esteem,
that they know what they're good at, and
that you're really fostering is
something that's really important.
>> Absolutely.
And you feel that's possible,
even within the context of
them being in the spotlight?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think that my view is,
I'm in the spotlight because of my role.
They aren't, right?
And I'm very protective of their routines,
their days.
You can scrutinize me.
Through my roles, I'm out there that way.
But that's not really fair to them,
and I think that overall there
hasn't been a big spotlight on them.
I think that their names are known, but
we're pretty careful
with what they look like.
>> Right.
>> Their identities, where they go,
all that type of thing.
>> Absolutely.
So, we have time for
one more question for me, and
then we'll open up to the audience.
But, fast forward a few months from now,
the Verizon acquisition closes.
What do you wake up, excited to do next?
Is it at Yahoo?
Is it outside of Yahoo,
within the tech community?
>> I mean, I think that right
now it's too early to say.
I mean we were working, overall in
closing the Verizon transaction.
And that's the most important thing
that I'm working on, right now.
But, given that reflection that I had last
summer of what am I most
proud of at Google?
And what am I most proud of at Yahoo?
It's really that it's rare privilege,
to work a company that changes the world.
Because there's lots of great
companies out there, but
there's a rare few that really change
the world, and change paradigms.
And I'm excited to work on that.
Whether that's at Verizon, or at Yahoo,
or somewhere else, but it's addictive.
That ability to, really try and
help change the world,
make an impact on the world for
the better.
And the fact that, we now have so many
tools that are available to our reach,
to really influence those kinds of
outcomes, is pretty amazing and
is an opportunity not to be lost.
>> I think I speak for
everyone in the audience when I say that,
I hope your future plans include,
teaching back here at Stanford.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]